hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the last
of us okay we just got this
awesome flamethrower and we have arrived
at the university of eastern colorado
which means that we are
close to the fireflies but i have a bad
feeling that
something has gone horribly wrong
because it does not seem
like they are quite prepared for this
infestation that they got going on i
mean i imagine that there would be
zombies all over the place come on
flashlight there would be zombies all
over the place
normally that's just how the world is
now but as far as i can tell
seems like the lookout posts are
abandoned
things don't look too good wait a minute
what's that oh this is a plant blowing
in the wind never mind
i'm getting jumpy i'm getting jumpy
because i'm seeing zombies around every
quarter
hey i was thinking i would have wanted
to be an astronaut
really that effect yeah
you imagine being up there all by
yourself would have been cool
i'm just saying well you wouldn't have
been up there by yourself but yeah it
would have been cool
you're right okay oh that's why i
started the generator okay
i'll stay with kallus all right you do
the name
yep see biscuit no juice
i just fired it up oh did i not fire it
up oh i didn't fire it up i was
up there oh i thought i did that in the
last part i'm so dumb
everyone ignore my stupidity right now
just look at me i'm making dumb
faces
laugh at me laugh at me
it's the curse of the clown you're
laughing at me
i'm never happy oh wait i play video
games for a living hey
hey all right
i can't believe i didn't do this i was
writing for i was standing right there
got it that one's slower than the other
ones i don't know why
but anyway got that all taken care of
excuse me i'm very sorry that was
horribly rude
got that taken care of and we are on our
way i'm gonna try to get into this
in a relatively rough quick manner not
distracting myself with a bunch of
stupid stuff
oh by the way i did get the other hole
through what other gun do i want here
that's exactly what i wanted the shorty
and the el diablo
the game knows me it knows me so well
shotgun and flamethrower shorty el
diablo i think is a great combination
what about you what do you want to be
well when i was a kid i used to want to
be uh
a singer shut up i'm serious
sing something oh no come on i won't
laugh
i don't think so yeah you'll laugh
please
is he gonna sing something oh he's not
gonna sing anything
he's too shy come on
whoa monkeys infected monkeys
i guess the lab animals escaped a while
ago or there's a zoo around here
weird i guess that would happen
never thought to think about that i
never thought to think you heard me
you heard me okay how are we getting to
that building over there
this place seems big almost perfect
place for an ambush right
i don't like the look of this
it's a nice campus you know look
fireflies real fireflies or fakey fakey
fireflies oh real fireflies there's a
symbol on this door there
okay still looking for a way in
oh look yeah we see yeah i see i see
this is good first sign of fireflies
still
all right then let's get a move on run
right into that ambush
i know it's coming all right let's try
that gate
disconnect generator when not on duty oh
really
you're gonna make ellie do it okay i'll
be right back
is this not working here all right fine
then here we go
crawling under hello hello
supplies thank you supplements what's
that
ooh campus map okay uh
zoom in getting slammed here must beef
up barricades infected slipping through
here need to reinforce all stadium
and bookstore exits
snipers and ask okay we're right about
in the center of that area i believe and
that's the science building that's
circled in the top left over there
so all right then we're getting pretty
close to our goal
where's this generator let's be upstairs
let's pull out a gun not gonna get
ambushed
well i'm probably gonna get ambushed but
i'm not gonna be surprised by it
hello shivable no
oh grody
what did i just pick up paper cloth i
don't know
nice computers
this place is disgusting probably
disgusting even before the zombie
apocalypse
ew you can find porn and condoms
okay students journal let's see what it
says nine goddamn months of waiting is
still nothing no word from anyone
cans of food okay so it seems like
people were barricaded up in the uh
in this place here let's see
oh they were smoking oh they threw away
the stash
i don't know how long do you think they
held down
i've heard something it was either a dog
or i don't know what it was
okay interesting dorm design
damn it spores really spores here
time for the flame thrower hope i get
more ammo
damn it you gotta be joking me all right
down we go
oh oh oh oh oh
oh holy crap
that's a lot of them and that's a
clicker right up in front
let's see if we can't deal with these
guys in a spectacular fashion
what was that you want to check that out
boom got one clicker i think
where's the rest oh [ __ ]
there we go down whoa whoa where'd you
come from
got that one come on whoa you're on
loader
where'd you come from that's not fair
where's my where's my damn
take that [ __ ] get out of here [ __ ] off
you burn
you burn to death and i will stay way
over here how about that
[ __ ] come on flashlight okay let's go
let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go yeesh you
still on fire or
you just pretending to be no you're
still on fire
let's see does he need an extra
convincing
chuckles at him anyway i got him on fire
that'll probably finish him off i think
that'll do it
i probably didn't even need to throw
that because just run for it oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's coming oh oh
he's on fire and on his way
ah scary scary scary scary
i didn't have to throw that second
multiple that was a waste hi buddy
hey there how you doing i'm gonna craft
some molotovs
don't need that ooh i can get the second
weapon sway i'll be
so accurate sweet
i didn't know that i had that many
supplements must be from all the
scavenging that i've been doing
correctly
correctly okay
here man why did i leave ellie alone
where's this damn generator
it's got to be somewhere here all right
oh really more infected i'm fine oh okay
i see
here come up on the gate yeah i'll do it
please don't tell me what to do ellie
ah really
what the wait what what am i doing here
wait a minute i gotta hook this up to
this is that what i gotta do here
all right ready genius i'm a genius
all right let's do this bug
got it i think i killed the bug too
and whoopty here we go
ellie can do it on the first side of the
gate it takes me a few
oh hello come on
good thing that horse isn't too skittish
scooch
scoot your boots all right let's go
those clickers
do you think they were fireflies no
no i don't think so looked like they
were students why would they have
infected so close to the lab
well bill used them as a form of defense
maybe they're doing the same
yeah i could see that oh okay i see a
flashlight
i guess they are an effective barrier
all right we're here i can't believe it
we're here
impressive no guards no nothing
not a good sign i'd expect to see
someone by now
it makes you wonder why it's abandoned
you can't jump over that where can we
get in
well is that illuminated red is that
important
there's got to be some way in definitely
not here
maybe over here
let's see garage maybe let's go
hey what about over there yeah that
looks like the way in
uh-huh all right then so
let's see about getting this open
nice rusted shut i'll have to find
another way
if you say so maybe we can get over it
how
oh i know how ooh is there something we
could oh no
hmm there's got to be something we could
use
maybe this this this this yep got it
sweet
nice solar panel arrays they got going
on there
things they made that explains why they
have power somewhere
there we go that'll do it
i know what i had in mind but it'll do
sweet all right we're inside let's find
these some
fireflies or whatever's left of them
hello okay now through there down here
through here maybe no
well then where are we going ah okay got
up on the truck up on the truck
maybe no oh i got to get the cart duh
duh i'm an idiot
don't see how if we'd had gotten in the
gate without this we wouldn't be able to
continue anyway
so i guess this is for the best
and squadron me first get out of the way
ellie you don't deserve to go first
civilization i'm so ready
so uh i guess we can just climb up wait
is there something over here
uh nope okay climb right up you mate
excuse me ellie galloway me first
something bad gonna happen all right
we're inside
come on kiddo give me your hand nice
yump there haley
whenever they do a cut scene like that
on i think something bad's gonna happen
okay there's bound to be lots of cool
supplies in this science area
let's paint ammo cool supplies gun ammo
that's the first part of science kicking
ass
okay let's see what's in here nice
lots of parts and a workbench but i just
fixed up my stuff i don't need another
one
why they got another one right here when
i haven't seen one for about two hours
who knows maybe they're all dead
you ever think about that ellie
sweet anything else i can craft
yes but yeah okay any more bombs
okay good on shivs we're fine okay
shivable fireflies
care for mankind over here anyone
let's keep it down until we figure out
what's going on i guess i just follow
ellie
okay what do we got going on here
nothing useful but a bunch of medical
mumbo jumbo
i don't get it looks like they all just
packed up and left in a hurry
oh maybe not all of them
stay close yeah maybe they relocated to
another science facility
because i'm pretty sure we still have to
go through winter so the end of the game
is not here
hello who's there who wants a piece
of me and all that i have to who out
there wants a piece of me
no no one okay
hello ellie open the door ellie open the
door
open the door ellie thank you ellie
why is ellie leading the way am i using
her as a human shield
that's good right we found out where
they went
whoa quarantine tent finally a brick i
haven't seen bricks or bottles in
forever but i guess that means comet's
about to happen
oh [ __ ]
so it's what's clickers right oh
clickers don't hide
what the hell what is going on wait what
why are you just moving forward ellie i
don't like the look of this i'm going in
here
getting supplies ellie you just brave
the
great beyond over there and i'll oh i'll
just keep looking for supplies
why are there so many bricks i guess i'm
going to be coming through here again
i got a bad feeling and every time i've
had a bad feeling so far it's been
confirmed
looks sciencey
fungal x-rays this would be interesting
whoa
uh yeesh that don't look good
oh man grody oh it doesn't look like fun
but whatever
okay anything useful ellie cause i don't
see anything
nothing it's gone ellie it's not there
anymore
i picked it up ellie i've already picked
it up okay
i guess through here
bad feeling bad feeling whoa oh it's a
monkey
monkey no fireflies either true
well maybe in all that research they
turned into [ __ ] monkeys
just keep searching we'll find something
what is this
lab recorder okay play
that's four pallets of lab equipment all
packed up and ready to go
now big question is what do we do with
all you guys
they say the tainted batch needs to be
put down you know what i say
say screw that who made a bigger
sacrifice than you right
if anyone deserves to run free out there
easy
oh my god and the winner of the dumbass
award
really wow really i'm sure glad we
didn't mess with them monkeys
he didn't see where they went i know
let's just keep looking
wow that guy was grade a
stupid oh my god run free monkeys
run free you infected disease-carrying
monkeys
okay whatever
i guess since humans and monkeys are
kind of similar
there would be some parallels drawn
hello sir are you all right you don't
look so good in here
look a little uh on the malnourished
side
that guy blew his brains out here we go
they're looking for the fireflies
they've all left
yeah no [ __ ] i'm dead or i will be
soon got me some time to reflect
and years that felt like we were [ __ ]
thing was a giant wasted time i'm not
gonna do this anymore
looking for the others they've all
returned to saint mary's hospital in
salt lake city
i'll find him there still trying to save
the world
good luck with that do you know where
that is
i know the city is it far
it ain't close horseback
what fireflies
get down
how did they spot him bandits
what are they doing here [ __ ] are these
guys soldiers
don't matter we know where to go let's
get the hell out of here
man where did all my sniper ammo go not
that i had that much to begin with
okay these guys are gonna get a face
full of shorty
okay just creeping along i'm gonna take
this very slow
very quietly run run run run quiet
quiet is the key
no you don't [ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ]
yeah no joke that was just whoa whoa
whoa whoa
no you don't oh no you do not it's been
a while since ellie jumped on someone's
back maybe she wants to
help out here just a little bit okay
that didn't go quite as i planned but
we're all right
i'm gonna knock this over don't need
that bugging us
here honey oh my god
where did they all come from good job
ellie i'm gonna go to the right side
this is why i got the brick this is why
all those bricks were there because i
had a feeling we'd be coming back here
okay where is he right there
there's two of them coming through here
come on come on come on it's going
around
all right
cover me up
there we go
down whoa whoa whoa how did i not get
hit there
there we go whoa whoa where'd you come
from buddy you want to get a facebook
axe
there we go another one down [ __ ] we got
to get out of here
let me get out of here ellie
okay just hold on ellie hold them off
jump on their back or something
call me off guard i'll have it again
well it probably will happen many many
more times but
won't happen again right now anyway i've
only got one more
charge for my thing i'm gonna bonk this
guy
come here come back here hey come back
and take your lumps
you started this fight you're gonna
finish it
attaboy just like that shoot again
there we go headshot nailed him there
was a guy with an axe over here i wish
i wish he'd dropped it but apparently he
did not yeah
yeah there it is all right all right all
right
let's do this why do these no seriously
why do these guys even bother
why why why would we why why would we do
we i can't talk
do i have a brick okay good i have a
brick okay looking for more
there's bound to me more i'm gonna brick
someone in the face any day now
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay come on up nope
go go go go ellie ellie ellie come on
come on come on kelly we got to move
come on ellie okay they're coming up
see that guy's gonna go around the door
i think or at least i hope so
okay he's coming this way come on ellie
i screw it we're going for it
just like that that's how we do it
this is how we do it can i grab this guy
probably
come on buddy
got you
i shouldn't laugh maniacally at that but
i i like
taking out humans much more than i like
zombies well not not that i
i'm not saying no way that's not what i
mean i didn't say like i'm a psycho
crazy i like
killer demons no i mean it's more fun
because they're they actually think and
you can outsmart them
it's satisfying to pull off a plan i'm
not saying i like just
don't don't twist my words that's not
what i said that's not what i said i'm
not crazy
where's the blacksmith no okay enough
there's one more down here that we gotta
take care of wish i had another brick
but i do not so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna just do this the
old-fashioned way with a shorty to the
face
hey buddy how's it going friend you the
only one around here
good see i'm probably just gonna be able
to grab you when you come around this
corner and then i'm gonna strangle you
hey buddy your friends are all dead over
here you want to come over here and find
them
damn it screw it
maybe i can shoot this guy in the face
was he actually coming over here now
no he's not he's just looping around
because he's an idiot
done and done
all right let's see what we're doing
here
whoa hey whoa
no you don't ellie anything now ellie
help would be greatly appreciated
ellie oh
wow
what do you want me to do what
oh man
you ready one two three
seriously not joel not now this can't be
good
no no no no no no way no way no how
i'm fine i'm not fine
i cut through intestines and stuff it's
not good
all right just stay here
really
all right those were my friends you
killed [ __ ] too bad come on out
you want to do this the hard way i'll do
this the u dead way
here we go
oh no come on keep it together joel
i'm okay you're not okay joel
now come on thanks for the motivational
speak ellie
you gotta reload oh man
this is not hurry
why do you guys keep coming after us you
know we're gonna kill you
sons of [ __ ] you're doing good just
keep at it
why didn't ellie help me out back there
jump on the guy's back
here lean on me no well can you walk
yes then [ __ ] walk joel stop being
such a tough guy
just take some help damn it
come on where's the horse i don't even
know where the horse was left
just a little bit more come on man
went through his intestines he's
probably bleeding out as he speaks
come on let me shoot let me shoot [ __ ]
let me shoot let me shoot
good job ellie you did good stand up
put your arm around me all right let's
go
all right let's go let's go
i swear to god i get you out of this
you're so singing for me
wish
wait here i'll get the door take your
time
there you go that's what you get
come
can you get on
man that sucks
that sucks
somehow we got to get all the way to
salt lake city with him injured like
that
i think we're safe
[ __ ] jewel here
oh get up get up get up
you gotta tell me what to do come on
you gotta get up
ooh
brutal poor bunny
this won't last very long
gotta eat somehow
you'll just startle it
where's joel
where's joel
where'd you go where's joel
where's joel there he is
where's y'all
is y'all okay is joel dead
i don't think joel is dead i think
joel's just back at camp that's what i'm
gonna believe and no one's gonna tell me
otherwise
joel is not dead joel's back at camp
she's just out hunting for food for
while he's recovering
it's fine it's fine it's fine totally
totally gonna be fine
all right i'm gonna get this dear good
thing i've been upgrading my bow
where'd you go well she's learned the
hearing technique where is this damn oh
there it is
whoa oh dear oh dear
you don't see me dear
it's just beyond those trees there
that's the objective now that's all i
gotta focus on is making this
shot and making it count
come on get over that log no no no
no no no no no
come on make it over the log get over
the log ellie fine go around it
damn it gotta be more quiet damn it
ellie what the hell ellie screwing
everything up
probably cut it off through here
where is it there it is okay
i can make this no more cramping our
trees cause there are bushes near the
trees they just got to be very
very very stealthy
you don't hear a thing dear okay i can
be a little quicker now because
i'm farther away from it stay away from
sticks
nope oh nope you didn't hear a thing
you didn't hear a thing dear that's what
i thought
okay no bushes no sticks
no branches everyone shut up
everyone be very quiet can i make this
shot from here
i could i could make the shot need to
hit his heart about
right there hang on i'll make the shot
again easy easy
come on stop swaying ellie
got you gotcha now i just got to follow
it until it bleeds out
i don't know if i got his heart all you
hundreds out there are probably like
that was a terrible shot well it's a
little girl and she's
swaying all over the place it was far
away and i i couldn't make it i know
i had i didn't have breakfast this
morning and i was i'm tired and i'm a
little thick i got cranky
didn't get enough sleep last night and
and the moons aren't in the right orbit
and you know you know you know excuses
excuses excuse me
[ __ ] what is it still live damn it i
gotta hit it again i didn't get it right
okay probably gonna hit it again
still bleeding but at least there's a
trail now
where's it at it's bleeding quite a bit
so probably running out of use
probably not gonna be very s very easy
to follow because it's going to be
easily startled
okay it's still there it's not dead yet
this is a long shot but
really it just decided to graze here for
a bit it was shot with an arrow and it
thinks it's perfectly okay
only his leg his leg is kind of broken
okay do this again
damn it did i get it oh man
am i does it want me to aim for the head
is that what it wants me to do
because i don't think i'm gonna be able
to get that head shot
might have been i didn't even think i
was going to hit it then
how are you still alive that's the
question
whoa where did it go where'd it go
[ __ ]
where did it go
where did you go you stupid tall
horse short horse thingy you're just
half a horse you're not even a full
horse
you're like a fake horse that's all you
are you stupid deer with your antlers
poking up out of your head
you know how stupid you look with that
the answer is very
okay what is this mine of some sort
what is this place it's almost as if i
was being led here
hmm how strange
it seems to have gone in there
but where where did it go
everything's cool yep
this place is not creepy at all no way
no how
just got to be very simple everyone just
be quiet out there
there's a deer and there's potential
zomzoms everywhere
i hope those zomzoms aren't nibbling on
my deer
where are you where are you
oh you're dead okay good about time
oh yes
hey no one take this from me this is my
dear by the way no one's gonna jump me
right who's there
come out
hello we just want to talk
too bad no talking sun moves and i put
one right between your eyes ditto for
buddy boy over there
what do you want name's david
this here's my friend james but from a
larger group
women children they're all very very
hungry
so am i women and children all very
hungry too
well uh maybe we could uh trade you for
some of that meat there
what do you need weapons
ammo clothes medicine
do you have any antibiotics
we do back at the camp
welcome to following i'm not following
you anywhere
buddy boy can go get it he comes back
with what i need
the deer is all yours anyone else shows
up you put one right between my eyes
that's right
two bottles of the penicillin in a
syringe make it fast
go on
i'll take that rifle
of course no sudden moves
but buddy boy
it's probably gonna be a while you uh
mind if we take some shelter from the
cold
bring him with us
the plus side is joel is still alive
that's the only reason she would want
medicine
there
you know you really shouldn't be out
here all on your own
i don't like company i see
what's your name joe why
look i understand it's not easy to trust
a couple of strangers
nope whoever's hurt you clearly care
about them
i'm sure it's going to be just fine too
bad
don't trust you we'll see
uh-oh
you had another gun sorry
hey i really like my rifle back now no
you have your pistol
hope you know how to use that thing of
course i do had some practice
no matter what we have to keep them out
okay sounds good to me
ooh a three round chamber all right a
couple of the windows
okay looking out
anything anything anything anyone anyone
wants them oh you want some you want
something
okay that was a mess but you want some
you want something
sorry i get excited when i can make a
headshot it's so rare
oh and no headshot
oh hello where'd you come from
almost out of ammo here
one shot left can you take care of that
one or
no i got it here hold the rifle
another rifle you weren't kidding you're
a better shot with that thing than i am
oh okay i see ammo i like this rifle
better than the old one
no that's what what though
come on
excuse me pardon me this is uh we don't
want any
it
where did they all come from they just
started flooding in out of nowhere for
what reason
more infected they must have followed
what was that sound that was the sound
of an infection damn it
when they get close i can never shoot
them right
hello clicker reload reload reload
there we go
damn it i'll get these shots eventually
hey look i have a knife which means i i
have infinite killable ammo
maybe hello
take care of that one
gotta get some ammo ammo ammo ammo ammo
okay where are they oh buddy boy didn't
get killed
we're getting out of this room whatever
you say man i think we're doing just
fine before
there we go
all right do you know where you're going
i never set foot in this place oh great
so do i have craftables can i craft
stuff again
this way right behind you all right
how you holding up you don't need to
worry about me
yeah i've been through more than you
have buddy don't worry
come on
howie hey kid you all right i'm fine
more clickers get out of there
i'mma getting okay so now it's time for
stealth
okay i should be able to take these all
out with my bow here
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoops
okey dokey my bad i thought i could
or not once again i'm as bad with the
bow as
i'm the as bad with the bow as i ever
have been
got it damn it moved
they always move
got it let's hope i got some
recoverables over there
don't know if i do hope i do i think
that was all the clickers too
one more
there you are got yeah
okay all right that should do it that
should do it
got one arrow back what's down there i
don't want to know but i guess that's
where i'm going next
okay two three four
five arrows
brick finally brick someone
i like the brick tactic it's my fave
can i craft anything probably okay i'm
gonna need
i'm gonna need a medkit more than
anything else
where's all the supplies joel had tons i
guess she can't carry as much
because she would have no idea how to
carry a bomb anyway or make a bomb
anyway
maybe i don't know all right let's just
keep moving forward we're doing good so
far
whoa whoa whoa whoa i was about to brick
it all right
yeah i'm fine come on door's this way
took out more clickers than you did yes
i was so close i'm just playing a little
girl here yeah sucker you think you know
how to take out clickers
you immune like me damn
boost me up now i'm on the other end of
the boosting hey i said boost me up
boost me up here come here boost me up
finally i am on the other side of this
okay ready um there we go
there we go
all right moving on keep a lookout for
these things
okey dokey whoa
where are they i hear them all over the
place but i don't see any of them up
here
seriously how did these guys come to
swarming this entire area
hey buddy how you doing
you want a brick to the face how about
that
there we go got it
everything's fine don't
worry about it i got it it's all under
control man
all right
maybe i don't even need to stun them
maybe i can knife them because i have
this in
invincible knife here okay let's do this
i would i can i oh i want to do the move
where i jump on their back and just stab
them to death all over the place
all right so that's where we're going
here i hear them clicking around all
over the place
all right here i come
up the ladder we go yes through here
all right let's go let's do this come on
kid
i am coming along jeez stop bossing me
around you douche
oh that's not a good sound
yeah no [ __ ] you gotta watch your
language
shut up
okay this doesn't sound good
okay give me that give me that give me
that give me that
jeez looks like someone already fought
those things and lost
oh lord i've been looking for these boys
huh doesn't matter all the time grab the
gear
looks like we're gearing up for a fight
here
this should be good no need for shivs on
this girl i guess
excuse me pardon me can't understand you
what are you saying
what anything we can use you're a douche
is that it
see anything
what do we do we hold our ground all
right whatever you say man get ready
i'm ready are you ready
hello goodbye or i'll miss
had two
hello goodbye
hello clicky
oh come on there's such a narrow miss
all right all right all right all right
well where on the roof are they oh here
come here come on i'm gonna stab you
with this knife
and then i'm gonna die apparently [ __ ]
oh no oh no you don't
there we go i need another whoa no no no
no no
man this little girl can't take many
hits that seems strange but it's true
i'm coming yeah
there we go knife that one
whoa you're not dead really jesus these
things are
invincible
are we
okay all right all right okay
okay all right okay all right
man ellie's doing better with this bow
than joel ever did
come on what do we got there come more
where these things are there
i have no idea just keep at it
there we go that's the move oh i didn't
get to do the full move though
clicker clicker clicker clicker
wow why can't i hit i always miss by
that
much just never buy a big margin it's
always by the tiniest
that is a bloater what
burn [ __ ]
rub it in the crotch oh don't kill me
don't kill me i i don't want to die
don't kill me loader where are you
where's the bloater
get him get him up run away
she's like two hits and she always goes
she goes right down
see more rifle ammo is that bloater
still alive
there we go now you're down stay down
[ __ ]
yeah you know i think we did it yeah we
killed all of them
oh don't sound so disappointed more like
disbelief
man she cannot take a hit okay we're
still moving forward all right we're
doing fine we didn't die
hooray no death
is your buddy boy coming back any second
now
listen now infected
no infected what'd i tell you kill them
all
all right let's head on back check on
that buck of ours
don't act all buddy buddy with me joel
still wouldn't trust you he would finish
the job and then
still not trust you that's what joel you
handled yourself pretty nice back there
i'd say we make a pretty good team
we got lucky lucky no
no no such thing as luck
now you see i believe that everything
happens
for a reason like a zombie apocalypse
sure
i do and i can prove it to you
really can you this winter
that's been especially cruel
a few weeks back i am sent a group of
men out
nearby town to look for food
only a few came back
he said that the others had been uh
slaughtered by a crazy man
and get this he's crazy man traveling
a little girl
you see everything happens for a reason
ah don't get upset
it's not your fault
i'm just a kid shoot him in the face
james lower the gun
no way david i'm not gonna let her lower
a gun
now give her the medicine
the others won't be happy about this
yeah well that's not your concern
move the [ __ ] out of the way
won't survive long out there
i can't protect you
oh thanks
see i knew i shouldn't have trusted that
guy that guy's weird don't know what his
motivations are but why would he give me
the medicine again i don't understand
obviously his men deserve to die if joel
killed him he wouldn't just kill to kill
let's get out of here
i'm so confused right now so confused
but i guess that's okay
it happens confusing happens
okay
joel
i only managed to get a little bit of
food
but i did get this
move your arm
oh man
here we go
sorry hold on
that's it
man how did joel last this far already
he's one tough son of a [ __ ]
oh sweet
oh boy this ain't good
like i said bad feelings all around
oh [ __ ]
they tracked me kill them all
i'm gonna draw them away from here i'll
come back for you
interesting stuff i like it i love it
this story is so
intricate involved sometimes i just kind
of forget that i'm doing commentary here
i just get so distracted by the game
love it love it
god
there you go that's what you deserve but
david
all right all right all right all right
all right all right
let's go let's go
you want to run over by a freaking horse
okay don't don't let him get onto the
horse that's right get out of the way
how many of them do they have why
why so many
all right come on come on come on come
on come and get me
[ __ ] she's heading off what what
can't catch me what whoop
duck through here over here
what do they want i have no idea
seriously why do they want to catch this
girl so badly
don't shoot the horse don't shoot the
horse
no oh [ __ ]
and boop i'm all out of time
i know that's a horrible place to start
because i was like right in the middle
of this stuff but
i'm already going well over an hour so
god deposit here we'll start we'll start
this back up
immediately as soon as possible so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that i've
done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
oh
if